Did you get it?
>> Yeah I did actually. so, so this one
I think I understand completely. So we know that from
the last discussion we had about how you would recover
the joint, that what you're saying on the right of
this equation probability y times probability of x given y means that
the probability of y, the variable y doesn't depend on
anything. So, between those two graphs the one on the
right is the one where you're saying that. You don't
need to know the value of any other
variable in order to determine the probability of y.
>> Good.
>> So it has to be the one on the sec, the second and just to make sure
if you look at the second product the probability
of x given y the second multican? Is it multican?
>> Hm, factor.
>> Factor? Let's say factor. The second factor,
this says that while you determine the probability
of x given the value of y and there is an arrow from y to x
so, the second one is in fact correct.
>> Yeah. So this is actually just one way you could just read this
network is to say what is this node x with an arrow coming into it?
That is the probability of x. But, the, the things pointing into it are what's
exactly being given. What it's being conditioned
on. So that's exactly right, the second one.
>> Right. So this, this, so this makes sense to me. This is why when
you look at a network, a Bayesian  network, it's very
hard not to think of them as dependencies.
Even though they're not dependencies, they're conditional independencies.
>> Well the arrows are a form of dependence but it's not a causal
dependence necessarily, it's it's again it's just
the way the probabilities are being decomposed.
>> Hm.
>> And the last of these three equations just Bayes rule,
this time written correctly where the denominator has to be the probability
of x, and we've gone over this a couple of times. I
don't, I don't need to, to describe it again, but what Would
like to, just, bring to your attention to
this three together turn out to be kind
of our, you know, three musketeers in working
out the probability of various kinds of events.
>> Excellent.